[Applaudissements]
lui a fallu bernard ça lui paraissait
qui baisse et montrent qu'elles sont
calmes et julie
tu as fait ton portable avec lui lui est
fou tu arrêtes de te faire racketter par
mokhtar comme ça bon rien à un moment
donné faut que tu sois un homme tu
t'affirmes moi j'ai pas de problème à le
regarder dans les yeux mokhtar et lui il
dira m
que je lui file aussi mon téléphone
parce que moi je vois je t'ai vu déjà tu
téléphones énormément aimé moi j'ai un
forfait soirs et week-ends à beaucoup
mieux pourquoi pas ça tombe bien c'est
la perf à cette fille ça rouge tiens tu
tombe bientôt
et y'a mon pote je viens de voir quatre
hausses de toi je rêve de le contrer il
n'y avait plus haut face à bath et
c'était un canular s'était pas non plus
le truc de la courte ou quad excès les
invités comme ça ça veut dire quoi
plus de miss cyril à dormir réunion n'a
plus les miss france on n'a plus rien à
jouer cette saison 9e qui vient plus les
missiles continuent à venir c'est que
geneviève les miss viennent une
promotion foot avec comme socom de hbos
avait subi un appel cyril on lui fait un
canular succès énorme mais bien sûr
c'est une robe vichy rapide anase
craquera casse et jacques chirac
vous êtes viré c'est non ça tapait les
jeunes anonymes et tuent les pièges
toute la journée quoi j'ai mon jeu je
t'ai pas ordonnée pour nîmes avant banon
moi depuis tout à l'heure je la sens pas
cette blague je t'ai dit chirac c'est
naze et franchement faire des blagues
lutté des années 80 qu'on me rappelle
grapel jeu oui bonjour vous êtes sur le
messager de jean-michel mer et sam way